You won't get nothing from me, young man.
I worked too hard in this life to let some...
Oh, you wanna end up dead?
No, please, don't hurt me.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Not on my watch, motherfucker.
You're hurting me!
No!
Help!
Help me!
Where is anybody ?
Is there nobody in this fucking world to help me for god sakes?!
Where's the fucking wallet?
Give me your fucking wallet.
Where is your fucking wallet?
[Undistinct screaming]
May I please speak with Laird?
No? Okay
No, just tell him that I called thank you!
Is somebody hearing me ?
Can you hear me ?! Help!
[Gunshot]
Aie ai aie
ok ok ok okaay
Wow, nice suit!
Zip it, Stan Lee!
[Music]
Oh, Jesus...
Ohhh...
That's not good.
No, no, no...
Oh, you're not gonna walk that one off...
Oh, that's so gross.
I'm so sorry.
No, I-I spent way too long in the phone booth.
If I'm being honest with myself,
I probably should have just called 911.
Well...
None of that matters now...
I guess I think you are both
missing the real point here.
The fuck is a phone booth
doing on a street corner?
They hadn't disappeared in '98?
Suppose I could've just used my cell.
Oouuh
Cherry Garcia ice cream!
You gonna eat this?
Don't answer now.
Just rest.
I mean, actually I made a call.
Went to the costumer.
His name is Laird. He usually helps me put a suit on.
I wonder how the other guys do it so quickly.
Well, you probably wouldn't be dead if it was Logan.
Cause what does he gotta change into... He wears the fucking tank top and a pair of jeans. Yeah...
[Australian Accent] Yeah. Like ta, get my tank top on. Bit of persperation
I have a little crime fighting spree yeee
Maybe 'Hug-a-Koala' day?